commence aujourd'hui les travaux en fait
de notre commission d'enquête qui a été
installée la semaine dernière sur donc
sur la pénurie de médicaments et les
choix de l'industrie pharmaceutique
française puisque
tout est lié de la production à la
dispensation
pour cette première audition nous
recevons donc Madame professeur
Dominique Le guludet qui est président
de la Haute Autorité de Santé
et Madame Fabienne Bartoli directrice
générale de la HS vous m'autoriserez à
dire HS
mes propos
d'ailleurs quand on dit HS les gens se
repèrent plus vite que avec haute
autorités de santé souvent
et donc merci beaucoup de vous être
mobilisés dans un délai aussi bref donc
si la HS n'est pas directement
responsable du suivi de la gestion des
pénuries elle est toutefois chargée
d'évaluer le service attendu des
médicaments et des mettre des avis sur
leurs conditions de prescription ou
d'utilisation
éminemment important et majeur au-delà
la HAS contribue à l'évaluation de la
qualité de la prise en charge sanitaire
de la population par le système de santé
c'est pourquoi il nous semblait
intéressant de vous auditionner le plus
tôt possible le plus
précocement possible dans le cas de
cette commission d'enquête afin
d'entendre d'emblée une analyse des
conséquences des pénuries sur la prise
en charge des patients puisque on ne
traite pas que une question quantitative
on traite bien évidemment une question
de santé publique la HAS est mis aussi
des recommandations de bonne pratique à
destination des professionnels de santé
et certifient les hôpitaux sans doute
pourrez-vous nous éclairer également sur
la manière dont les difficultés
d'approvisionnement affectent les
stratégies thérapeutiques ce qui
intuitivement Paris assez logique et
plus largement le travail des
professionnels de santé nous vous
interrogerons sur la meilleure manière
de les accompagner
et nous souhaiterions madame la
présidente Madame la Directrice générale
que vous puissiez formuler dans une
brève présentation introductive aux
principaux constats sur la situation
actuelle et sur le rôle de la Haute
Autorité de Santé
sur le rôle qu'elle peut être amenée à
jouer dans la prévention des pénuries où
les réponses à y apporter en sachant que
cette question des pénuries n'est pas
une question tout à fait récente même si
elle a connu une accusation particulière
pendant la période hivernale des de la
triple épidémie je passerai ensuite la
parole donc à Laurence Corrèze notre
rapporteur heureux de notre commission
d'enquête et je précise que cette
audition est diffusée en direct
sur le site internet du Sénat elle fera
l'objet bien évidemment d'un compte
rendu publié avant de vous passer la
parole madame la présidente Madame la
Directrice Gérard je vous rappelle qu'un
faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête et passible des peines prévues
aux articles
434-13
434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal et je
vous invite toutes les deux après tes
serments et de dire toute la vérité rien
que la vérité en levant la main droite
et en disant je le jure
je vous remercie madame la Présidente et
Madame la Directrice vous avez la parole
pour une intervention libinale et
ensuite nous passerons la parole donc à
notre rapporteur de façon à ce qu'elle
puisse lancer les échanges
il est évident qu'elles entraînent des
conséquences en matière de santé santé
pour les patients directement mais
également santé publique par exemple
quand il s'agit de vaccins
mais également probablement un
gaspillage de temps médical donc vous
savez pourtant qu'en ce moment il est
particulièrement précieux vu les
difficultés RH que rencontre notamment
nos hôpitaux alors
je tiens à dire quand même de façon
préliminaire que nous n'avons pas bien
que ce sujet
nous sommes soyons particulièrement
sensibles à ce sujet puisqu'il impact
directement la qualité des soins
nous ne disposons pas à la HS à rebours
de la NSM comme vous l'avez dit de
compétences dans la gestion des pénuries
qu'elle soit de vaccins ou de
médicaments
donc nous n'avons pas réellement de
vision
quantitative ou qualitative fine sur ces
phénomènes pour l'achat c'est amené à
intervenir dans des situations
particulières dont je vous donnerai
quelques exemples
un peu plus tard on pourra revoir par
contre
la HS est en charge de la politique
vaccinale et donc nous sommes
régulièrement amenés à ajuster modifier
la stratégie vaccinale pour répondre à
des situations potentielles de pénurie
alors quand il y a une pénurie de vaccin
on est fait nous proposons soit des
modifications de la stratégie soit des
priorisations soi-même des ajustements
de schéma vaccinal
et puis on l'a vu pendant la crise covid
on peut pas dire que c'était une pénurie
mais c'était une arrivée de dose
progressive donc une pénurie relative
par rapport aux besoins je dirais et
bien des priorisations de population
vacciner
dans des cas particuliers alors on peut
citer aussi la vaccination contre les
infections à pneumocoque
qui avait qui s'était produite et qui
nous avait amené à c'était en 2018 il y
avait eu des fortes tensions
d'approvisionnement en vaccin Pneumovax
et nous avions été saisis donc par le
directeur général de la Santé pour
prioriser les populations qui devaient
bénéficier de cette vaccination et puis
déterminer le schéma vaccinal
transitoire qui permettait de garantir
l'accès à cette vaccination pour ces
populations c'est un exemple
alors à cette période là la chaise avait
déjà déploré les épisodes répétés de
rupture de vaccin en particulier et les
difficultés que ça peut engendrer sur la
mise en oeuvre de la stratégie vaccinale
et la couverture avec sinale et nous
avions insisté pour que les dispositions
soient prises pour limiter ces ruptures
et
travailler sur la transparence quant à
leur cause
donc on avait dans cette recommandation
déterminer les populations prioritaires
et de même à nouveau sur le pneumocoque
pendant la crise covid au début de la
crise nous avons reprisé les personnes
qui susceptibles de bénéficier de cette
vaccination pneumovacs puisque là encore
en mars 21 et vu le contingentement de
cette spécialité
il fallait gérer au mieux les doses que
nous avions et donc nous avions rappelé
les populations prioritaires dans une
cas où la situation de pénurie se
maintiendrait au-delà des mesures de
confinement
encore une fois un autre exemple de
pénurie relative et on reparlera des
différentes causes de pénurie c'est la
stratégie vaccinale que vous avez pu
voir se mettre en place pendant le covid
et en effet les populations prioritaires
que nous avions déterminées dépendait au
fil de l'eau des doses que la France
recevait et donc évidemment on
élargissant la population prioritaire en
fonction des doses voilà alors parfois
sur ces in nous pouvons également
répondre aux alternatives lorsqu'un
produit est en pénurie
par exemple
mais c'est de façon marginale par
rapport à la NSM en 2016 il y avait une
pénurie de techniciens 99 qui est un
produit radioactif qui permet de faire
des examens qui sont essentiels et la
NSM avec les sociétés savantes avaient
priorisé gérer cette pénurie de
techniciens nous avions été par exemple
interroger sur une situation très
particulière qui est celle de la femme
enceinte quand il y a une suspicion
d'embolie pulmonaire puisque le scanner
il y a des alternatives à cet examen
mais qui peuvent être plus irradiantes
et donc il était nécessaire de bien
déterminer la procédure les bonnes
procédures la bonne prise en charge
d'une femme avec une suspicion d'embolie
pulmonaire d'une femme enceinte voilà
donc avec des situations assez
particulières sur lequel nous sommes
interrogés pour faire face aux
alternatives possibles et aux bonnes
conduites à tenir en situation de
pénurie
dans ce que fait la chas en dehors de
ces interventions qui sont comme vous le
voyez assez ponctuel dans le covid je
citerai aussi nous sommes intervenus
vous savez que pendant le covid la SAS
a pris l'initiative de pour aider les
professionnels qui étaient extrêmement
gêné dans leur pratique et très perdus
dans leur pratique soit liées au
confinement soit la pathologie elle-même
nous avions fait de ce qu'on appelle des
réponses rapides c'est-à-dire ce sont
des recommandations très rapides qui
n'ont pas toute la base scientifique
qui est une recommandation de la HS
habituelle mais qui est faite avec des
professionnels avec des patients
toujours avec les mêmes méthodes de
rigueur et puis de
d'absents de liens d'intérêt de contrôle
déontologique mais de façon très très
rapide c'est à dire qu'on a un groupe de
travail qu'on a mobilisé en permanence
et nous avions été
sollicités pour la prise en charge médic
de situation d'anxiolyse et de sédation
à un moment
où le midazole a mis le midasola était
[Musique]
ou dans les soins palliatifs donc nous
avions effectué ce type de travail pour
aider les professionnels à mieux gérer
ses patients
un dernier exemple de qui me paraît
intéressant avant de peut-être reprendre
le questionnaire et répondre plus
précisément à vos questions c'est ce que
nous faisons par rapport
au logiciel d'aide à la prescription et
à la dispensation et nous intervenons
sur des systèmes d'aide à la décision
indexée par médicament ça s'appelle des
Sam dans le jargon que les pharmaciens
connaissent bien et les médecins
connaissent bien également et
en pénurie par exemple très récemment on
peut nous demander ce sont alors
qu'est-ce que c'est que ces systèmes
d'aide
ces systèmes d'aide à la prescription
c'est en fait des pop-up qui
apparaissent dans les logiciels métiers
des médecins quand ils vont prescrire un
médicament et un message peut leur être
délivré et par exemple attention ça peut
être une contre-indication enfin en
temps normal ça peut une aide à la
prescription les alerter sur certaines
choses et là on peut les al passer sur
le bon usage et en partie où les
alternatives en situation de pénurie
pour l'amoxicilline nous avons fait un
tel logiciel très rapidement de façon à
pouvoir chaque fois que déjà évité
toutes les
mauvaises utilisations puisque voilà il
y en a la pertinence ni soins est-ce
qu'elle est aujourd'hui et donc il y en
a donc déjà favoriser la bonne
utilisation et puis encourager les
alternatives
faire respecter les durées de traitement
etc ces logiciels sont qui sont destinés
à un décret ces petits pop-up qui sont
destinés à être intégrés dans les
logiciels d'aide à la prescription ou à
la dispensation pour les pharmaciens
prescriptions pour les médecins
dispensation pour les pharmaciens
sont extrêmement utiles
en particulier nous on les utilise enfin
il nous semble très intéressants pour ce
qui est la pertinence des prescriptions
évidemment mais
ils peuvent être difficiles à
implémenter parce qu'il dépend de
évidemment
[Musique]
des éditeurs de logiciels et de leur
rapidité d'intégration de ces outils
numériques d'aide au professionnel
dans les logiciels voilà donc en fait
nous nous faisons
[Musique]
nous veillons enfin nous publions ces
outils mais ensuite après il faut qu'il
soit intégré dans des logiciels et
peut-être que là il y a quand même à mon
avis des outils qui pourraient être
mieux utilisés
dans cet usage
alors pour ce qui est pour revenir de
façon plus globale au pénurie
ce que nous constatons la chasse c'est
que il y a plusieurs situations de
pénurie bon il y a une citation une
situation qui est
d'augmentation conjoncturelle extrême de
la demande
ça c'est une chose
et
mais c'est un cas un petit peu
particulier il y en a d'autres qui sont
également conjoncturels et qui sont
liées à un problème de survenue dans un
processus de fabrication complexe et
donc qui ne résulte pas ni d'une
stratégie de laboratoire ni d'une
modification de la demande de la dans ce
médicament par exemple pour un vaccin
des vaccins vivants vous savez que c'est
un problème de un processus de
fabrication qui est très complexe et si
il peut y avoir des soucis dans la dans
la chaîne de production et donc on peut
se retrouver
à court de vaccins liés à des problèmes
dans la chaîne de production
et ce n'est pas ce n'est pas rare
d'autres une autre cause par contre qui
est totalement différente de ces deux
premières causes c'est celle qui peuvent
résulter d'un désintérêt des industriels
pour des vaccins anciens alors je suis
vaccin ça pourrait être totalement
superposés aux médicaments et qui sont
considérés comme peu rémunérateurs alors
qu'il conserve une place importante dans
la stratégie thérapeutique qu'elle soit
de traitement ou le vaccination et donc
les indications peuvent rester
importantes pour des vieux médicaments
qui sont
voilà qui sont anciens et qui donc sont
pas du tout les prix des médicaments qui
arrivent sur le marché
et puis enfin il y a une dernière cause
de choix qui sont des choix commerciaux
des laboratoires
de pousser ou pas un médicament je crois
qu'il leur appartiennent dans la
stratégie
d'entreprises et également des choix
dans la répartition des stocks entre
pays qui peuvent qui peuvent évoluer au
gré de nombreux facteurs
alors je ne suis absolument pas en
capacité de vous livrer des éléments
quantitatifs sur chacune de ces
situations
mais quand même on peut constater que
les augmentations encore une fois en
dehors des augmentations de demande
aiguës les processus liés à enfin des
problèmes liés à la fabrication des
produits sont deviennent de plus en plus
fréquents
même si ça ne fait pas partie de nos
missions une des pistes d'amélioration
qui nous semble vraiment
devoir être creusés c'est vraiment la
collaboration européenne entre état
parce qu'il y a ce qui peut être géré au
niveau de la France entre la NSM qui qui
est dont c'est la mission et aider par
toutes les autres agences mais
je dirais que le problème est général et
que une gestion au niveau européen a
davantage de sang de chance d'être
efficace
alors celle-ci cette démarche a déjà
commencé quand même d'abord avec
l'Agence européenne du médicament qui
s'est vu donner des nouvelles missions
sur ce sujet et puis la nouvelle entité
era qui pourrait avoir aussi un rôle à
jouer pour des achats groupés mais là
dans des situations un petit peu
particulière
pour ce qui est de la raison économique
il est clair qu'elle n'est pas
elle ne peut pas être exclue mais que il
est pas du tout certain que
remonter les prix de ces médicaments
suffirait à
je dirais à faire régresser les pénuries
vous savez que les stratégies
d'élaboratoires sont en particulier sur
la production
sont très liées à des phénomènes
mondiaux et donc une augmentation des
prix en France n'aurait qu'un impact
probablement modéré
et puis enfin pour tout ce qui est
pénurie
inévitable c'est-à-dire que de toute
façon peuvent survenir comme comme les
problèmes dans les process de
fabrication
ce qui nous semble vraiment important
dans la mesure où on ne peut pas les
éviter c'est de les anticiper au mieux
de les anticiper au mieux de façon à se
proposer des stratégies alternatives que
ce soit vaccin dans un calendrier
vaccinal que ce soit médicament pour le
traitement et et voilà d'informer les
professionnels les patients et d'avoir
je dirais près
des stratégies alternatives maintenant
ce qu'il faut quand même savoir c'est ce
sont quand même des raisons très
complexes
multifactorielles et que il y a autant
de situations quasiment que de pénurie
et que donc des solutions globales je
dirais un peu magique malheureusement
voilà
ils sont pas évidentes
puisque les raisons ne sont pas sont
souvent
associés plusieurs
voilà comme propos liminaire je voulais
pas prendre davantage de votre temps et
voilà après on peut rentrer dans vos
questions
dans le vif des questions
je ne savais pas qu'on était les
premiers auditionnés donc parce que donc
j'ai pas fait de je dirais de tableaux
de la situation d'abord parce que je
pense qu'elle ne m'appartient pas mais
puis que encore une fois notre rôle à la
chas est relativement modeste sur ce
domaine
c'est parfait parce que
exprimé merci beaucoup de ces propos
liminaires déjà assez complet et dense
donc je vais laisser
ma collègue Laurence Cohen rapporteur
nous faire
présenter ces questions et donner ses
éléments de dialogue
merci Madame pour ce propos liminaire et
effectivement il faut bien commencer une
commission d'enquête donc vous êtes les
premières
à commencer donc à nous apporter un
certain nombre de réponses vous avez
reçu un questionnaire qui est
extrêmement complet qui est très
fouillée il y a il y a une douzaine de
questions vous avez vu que vous pouvez y
répondre par écrit parce que
effectivement elle nécessite
d'approfondir chacun des aspects qui
vous sont posés mais à la lumière de ce
que vous avez dit Madame permettez-moi
peut-être d'insister sur quelques points
certains figures d'ailleurs dans les
questions qui vous ont été qui vous ont
été remises mais pas toutes
effectivement vous êtes positionné
d'emblée j'allais dire sur la
problématique vaccinale puisque c'est
votre terrain si je puis dire plus de
compétences par rapport à l'Agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament
mais il y a quand même des similitudes
qu'on peut qu'on peut tout à fait
appréhender d'ailleurs que vous avez
souligné entre les pénuries de certains
médicaments et également les pénuries ou
le manque ou etc au niveau au niveau des
des vaccins donc moi j'aimerais
à ce propos vous poser peut-être
quelques quelques questions c'est à dire
que vous avez dit notamment parmi les
causes qu'elles sont multifactorielles
je crois que là on partage tout tous et
toutes ce point de vue parmi les causes
j'avais dit bon il y a la question de
des problèmes sur les chaînes de
production je pense que c'est d'autant
plus vrai pour les vaccins parce que
c'est quand même très très spécialisé il
y a quand même une concentration aussi
une restriction ou je sais pas
rétrécissement plutôt du nombre des
usines qui qui assurent la production du
coup quand il y a un problème sur une
des chaînes et bien ça entraîne des
conséquences qui sont extrêmement
extrêmement importantes donc des
problèmes sur les chaînes de production
des intérêts vous avez dit de la part
des industriels pour certains produits
qui n'apparaissent comme peu rentables
et troisième chose les choix commerciaux
au niveau des laboratoires on peut tout
à fait le transposer ça au niveau au
niveau des des médicaments et je
voudrais peut-être avoir un petit peu un
approfondissement sur
les les
les vaccins et les produits qui
apparaissent comme peu rentables parce
que qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
finalement peu rentable on a entendu à
plusieurs reprises le fait de dire que
bon il suffirait
de d'augmenter les prix et puis tout
d'un coup comme par miracle les choses
rentreraient dans l'ordre on voit bien
que c'est beaucoup plus complexe que ça
et donc j'aimerais avoir des précisions
sur
qui est-ce qui qui considère que tel ou
tel produit et peut est rentable parce
qu'il y a la rentabilité financière mais
il y a aussi la réponse aux besoins des
populations et peut y avoir une
dichotomie d'ailleurs entre les deux
donc avoir un votre point de vue et
savoir si la HAS est en capacité à les
pouvoirs de pouvoir d'intervention à ce
moment là pour remettre un peu
un certain cadre par rapport à ces
assez difficultés ensuite j'aimerais
bien aussi peut-être que vous nous
disiez
finalement
c'est le fait que ces choix
puissent
avoir des conséquences plus ou moins
importantes sur les pertes de chance au
niveau au niveau des patientes et des
patients donc avoir là aussi votre votre
expertise concernant ces éléments
troisième
volet peut-être que j'aimerais vous voir
approfondir c'est concernant la
constitution de stocks
parce que on parle beaucoup et on en a
encore parlé là puisqu'on a fait une
visite dans une pharmacie
les stocks donc on dit de moi
sur les médicaments mais en fait on a
appris nous en tant que législateur que
en fait c'est purement déclaratif
c'est-à-dire que on déclare que
effectivement il y a deux mois de stock
mais visiblement
il semblerait je vais employé
inconditionnel qu'il n'y ait pas de
contrôle et que les déclarations soient
crues et que les stocks soient avérés ou
pas est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner
nous donner des éléments sur cette
question particulière et puis
est-ce que
est-ce que au niveau de donc des vaccins
comme comme des médicaments vous nous
avez dit que vous aviez la des
recommandations des des pour essayer de
d'abord d'encourager les bonnes
pratiques bien évidemment éventuellement
de fournir un certain nombre de pistes
on va dire alternatives mais là encore
sur quelle sur quel médicament ou vaccin
particulier est-ce qu'il s'agit de
traitement qui qui sont on va dire
anciens considérés comme peu rentable
etc ou non il n'y a pas de différence
entre ces
médicaments là ou ces vaccins là et ceux
qui sont plus récents et plus rentables
est-ce que vous vous voyez vous voyez
des différences et
peut-être enfin une dernière question
c'est
à la lumière de votre expérience en plus
de ce qu'on vient vivre de vivre avec la
covid quels sont de manière plus
pointues les propositions que vous
pourriez faire sur la gestion justement
de ces pénuries parce que de notre point
de vue on pense qu'elles peuvent être
améliorées pour ça que on est sur une
commission d'enquête donc est-ce que
vous avez vous des propositions précises
qui vont aussi dans ce sens je vous
remercie
alors pour pour votre
président depuis Madame la Directrice
générale si elle souhaite
alors pour ce qui est
de la rentabilité d'un produit alors là
je dois vous dire que
je crois pas que je sois la bonne
personne qu'il faut demander
comment un laboratoire juge que son
produit est rentable ou par rentable ce
que je peux moi dire c'est comment
comment est fixé les précieusement sont
fixés les prix des médicaments et quelle
est l'intervention de la chaise dans ce
dans cette fixation de prix
d'abord ce que ce que je veux dire c'est
que aujourd'hui on a énormément de
médicaments nouveaux qui arrivent par
rapport à j'ai passé 45 ans à l'hôpital
je peux vous dire que c'est c'est cinq
dernières années n'ont rien à voir avec
les décennies passées et il y a une un
nombre d'innovations et de médicaments
extrêmement important qui arrive mais ce
que l'on peut dire aussi c'est que ces
médicaments innovants tout à fait
intéressant les vaccins du covid en sont
un bon exemple à Irène messager arrive à
des prix inédits
et que ce soit des vaccins des
anticancéreux des tout ce que vous
voulez des médicaments arrivent des prix
très très chers alors nous ne sommes
absolument pas en charge de fixer les
prix mais par contre un la Commission de
la transparence
juge ces produits une fois qu'ils ont
une autorisation de mise sur le marché
par soit la NSM soit les mains au niveau
européen qui l'autorisation mis sur le
marché elle dit juste ce pays ce
médicament peut être commercialisé en
Europe OK ou en France en général c'est
sur Oui il fait ce qu'il prétend faire
et dans avec des risques acceptables
c'est ce qu'on appelle la balance
bénéficerie ça c'est du domaine des
agences régulatrices que sont la NSM ou
les mains au niveau européen
ensuite la deuxième question qui se pose
c'est
pour un état donné pour un État membre
dont la France évidemment c'est est-ce
que je souhaite rembourser ce médicament
c'est à qui soit prise en charge par la
collectivité et dans ces cas-là à quel
tarif et ça ça s'appuie sur c'est le
rôle de la chas par sa commission de la
transparence qui a deux critères un qui
évalue le service médical rendu je vais
pas vous détailler tout ce qui rentre
comme comme critère pour évaluer et qui
dit oui ce médicament bon un service
médical rendu faible puisqu'il y a trois
taux de remboursement
nul donc non remboursé faible modéré ou
élevé
beaucoup de médicaments étant encore
quand même pris à 100% pour les patients
en ALD même quand ils ont un taux de
remboursement plus régulier donc déjà
c'est la première chose que cette
commission dit faut-il ou pas rembourser
et à quel taux et puis le deuxième va
critère c'est l'amélioration du service
médical rendu c'est-à-dire ce produit
qui arrive comment se situe-t-il par
rapport aux anciens est-ce que dans la
stratégie thérapeutique il importe un
mieux pour le patient parce que tout ce
qui arrive qui est innovo n'est pas
forcément une inhibation
utile aux patient et ce critère là
s'appuie sur deux choses la quantité des
faits du nouveau produit comparé comparé
aux anciens et la qualité de la
démonstration avec lequel le laboratoire
vient or et c'est important de le savoir
avec cette
énorme activité d'innovation de nouveaux
médicaments
avec le fait que ces médicaments
arrivent de plus en plus vite auprès je
dirais des patients enfin et
l'accès aux patients soient accéléré
vous avez en France des processus qui
permettent même de les prendre en charge
dans des maladies graves
en amont de la même c'est-à-dire c'est
ce qui a remplacé les atténus c'était
les autorisations d'accès précoce donc
qui peuvent être un an avant la même sur
des données très préliminaires et
ensuite avec des prises en charge
également en accéléré c'est et l'Emma
qui donne des im de plus en plus
conditionnel
c'est-à-dire que avant d'avoir des
critères durs je dirais que
le degré d'incertitude avec lequel
arrive ces médicaments à la Commission
de la transparence n'arrêtent pas
d'augmenter donc c'est pour ça que cet
asmr varie selon la fois la quantité des
faits l'amélioration et de l'effet et la
qualité de la preuve qui parfois est
défectueuse
avec cette asmr ce SMR et cette asmr
avec ces deux indicateurs qu'ensuite le
CEPS va fixer les prix d'un médicament
voilà donc il va négocier de la
négociation avec les industriels qu'il a
n'appartiennent plus à la chaise et qui
va fixer les prix alors évidemment un
nouveau médicament qui arrive
aujourd'hui avec des innovations risque
d'être valorisées de façon beaucoup plus
importante qu'un médicament ancien
qui a été évalué il y a quelques années
dans un contexte totalement différent
donc ça je dirais que l'intervention de
la chaise sur le prix c'est là qu'elle
se situe ensuite la négociation
se passe ailleurs alors après est-ce
qu'il faut des questions qui peuvent se
poser c'est qu'il faut intégrer dans ces
critères le fait que par exemple le prix
le médicament soit fabriqué en France
est-ce qu'il faut intégrer d'autres
critères dans cette négociation de prix
ça
c'est plutôt de la du ressort de ceps
voilà c'est pour vous situer exactement
ce que fait chacun parce que je crois
que c'est important que que le rôle de
chacun voilà
Fabienne vous voulez peut-être compléter
oui enfin juste peut-être pour pour
appeler dans certains cas précis on peut
pas évidemment vous dire parce qu'on
n'est pas dans les comptes des
entreprises pour savoir ce qui est
rentable etc et on veut surtout pas y
être mais
si vous voulez en revanche que ce qu'on
peut constater c'est qu'il y a des vieux
produits qui sont sur le marché depuis
très longtemps et dont le prix est
relativement bas et que potentiellement
j'imagine mais ça c'est les discussions
que le ministère doit avoir avec les
industriels il est possible que un
certain nombre de coups qui lui ait
augmenté ne soit pas totalement reflétée
parce qu'il y a des très vieux
médicaments dans des niches parfois ça
arrive voilà mais peut-être que sur ce
point en tout cas
c'est clair que de toute façon c'est pas
du tout dans le ressort de la Haute
Autorité de Santé de décret avec
lesquels on fait des évaluations qui
doivent être vraiment faites sont les
critères scientifiques et médicaux comme
Dominique vient de l'expliquer
alors pour ce qui est des pertes de
chances elles sont indéniables quand il
manque d'un anticancéreux qui même s'il
n'est pas tout récent fait partie des
protocoles de chimiothérapie des
patients et qu'il faut trouver des
alternatives
quand il s'agit d'infection qui manque
un antibiotique alors que on sait que ce
germe est sensible à cet antibiotique
quand on parle de médicaments
d'anesthésie réanimation je parlais du
midazolam pendant la crise mais bon ça
peut être hors crise
les traitements des greffés par exemple
sont particulièrement sensibles parce
que c'est des traitements qui ne peuvent
pas être arrêtés c'est des traitements
au long cours mais qui ne peuvent pas
être interrompus voilà donc il y a des
risques il y a des pertes de chances qui
sont plus importantes évidemment plus la
maladie est sévère ou plus le traitement
est indispensable je veux dire mais on
ne peut pas le nier
voilà ça fait partie alors quand
évidemment ce que nous là nous sommes
sollicités c'est pour dans certains cas
particuliers trouver des alternatives
qui justement limite les pertes de
chances c'est-à-dire pour minimiser au
plus ces pertes de chance
vous m'inserrogez sur les stocks alors
là nous ne sommes vraiment pas en charge
des stocks
nous n'avons pas vraiment de vision ce
qu'on peut simplement dire c'est que ça
dépend aussi il y a des inspections qui
sont faites chez les grossistes
répartiteurs par les ARS et donc
en tout cas c'est plutôt eux qui
auraient une vision sur l'état de ses
stocks en tout cas oui ce que vous ont
dit c'est pharmaciens en effet sur le
fait que ce soit déclaratif et que ça
n'est pas forcément inspecté ça peut
l'être et si vous voulez l'inspection de
tous la chaîne grossiste répartiteur qui
alimentent les pharmaciens elles les
pharmacies
c'est dans les ARS les pharmaciens
inspecteurs qui sont en charge de cette
inspection mais vous pourrez poser la
question à la NSM qui surveille
alors donc qui est pas d'ambiguïté sur
les questions que j'ai posées c'est à
dire que
je n'ai pas de
je n'ai pas pensé que l'agent que la
Haute Autorité pardon de santé avait des
compétences là-dessus la question que je
vous ai posée n'est pas celle-ci
la question est plutôt à avec votre
expérience
et avec votre expertise
de votre point de vue à vous pas celui
de l'agence ni de l'ARS ni on va les
interroger il n'y a pas de problème mais
par rapport à vous vous qu'est-ce que
vous pensez en termes de stock qui
pourrait sécuriser c'est juste ça
peut-être que vous n'avez pas vous
n'avez pas suffisamment de voilà de
recul ou je ne sais pas enfin je ne veux
pas qualifier mais c'est plus par
rapport à vous parce que vous avez quand
même un retour en tout cas au niveau des
vaccins et vous pouvez à peu près avec
voilà
peut-être pas de façon exhaustive mais
pouvoir dire que on serait plus sécurisé
si voilà mais peut-être pas mais voilà
qu'on reste sur c'est votre champ de
compétences que je que j'interroge pas
celui
merci déjà la législation au 21 avait
prévu des stocks si mes souvenirs sont
bons c'était 4 mois pour les médicaments
d'intérêt thérapeutique majeur
et donc enfin c'était alors ça limitait
aux produits qui avaient fait l'objet de
pénurie
dans les deux ans précédents donc c'est
peut-être pas suffisant mais en tout cas
la démarche avait démarré à ce moment-là
pour essayer
je dirais de cadrer les stocks
nécessaires donc peut-être faut-il
élargir
cette disposition et je crois que enfin
nous participons à un comité
interministériel sur le sujet qui
cherche des solutions et en effet la
déjà
l'authentification de quel médicament
lesquels enfin la constitution d'une
liste je dirais des médicaments
prioritaires pour lequel il serait
important d'avoir ces stocks va
va être constituée
peut-être que alors il faut voir si
c'est les critères les monnaies de
définition de ce qu'on appelle les
médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutique
majeur est-ce qu'ils permettent de
couvrir l'ensemble dont les dans la
rupture pourrait constituer une perte de
chance ça il faut vraiment ça mérite
d'être travaillé je crois que ça va
l'être et voilà une participerons à ces
travaux ensuite
cette législation est-ce qu'elle est
appliquée déjà alors peut-être les
tentes mais est-ce qu'elle est appliquée
et là en effet bon c'est dur sort
peut-être d'inspection
et puis de pénalité le problème c'est
là c'est vraiment un peu personnel mais
c'est le problème c'est que les les
industries pharmaceutiques les
industriels sont des compagnies
mondiales maintenant multinationales
pour lequel le marché français
n'est pas un sujet je veux dire nous
représentons quand même relativement peu
de choses par rapport à leur production
mondiale et donc il est pas certain que
nos mesures nationales et un impact
important sur sur leur stratégie
mondiale et par exemple
c'est pour ça que je disais pour les
prix pour l'augmentation des prix c'est
ça peut-être une solution mais partielle
parce que évidemment j'imagine je ne
suis pas un industriel mais j'imagine
que centraliser complètement avoir
qu'une chaîne de production
représente des économies majeures pour
un industriel alors que le petit plus
qu'on va donner
voilà est-ce qu'il compensera voilà et
je dirais même quand on met des
pénalités si le gain de productivité
majeur que représente nos pénalités pour
un industriel il est possible aussi que
ce soit difficile
de se situer à ce niveau là voilà donc
je crois que en effet il y a la loi dit
qu'il faut des stocks il faut vérifier
que la liste de médicaments d'intérêt
thérapeutique majoré bien complète il
faut qu'elle couvre toutes les
situations délicates il faut faire
respecter cette loi par des inspections
après
qu'elle va être le résultat final voilà
c'est pas forcément évident il faut
pouvoir que quand même ce sont des
maintenant les entreprises
pharmaceutiques sont des multinationales
qui ont des intérêts mondiaux et je
dirais de façon plus générale que c'est
pour ça que la réponse européenne est
importante parce que le marché européen
avec des systèmes de santé très
solidaires comme un main qui prennent
beaucoup de choses en charge peuvent là
avoir un poids que nationalement nous ne
pouvons pas voir
et c'est vrai c'est vrai aussi pour pour
les médicaments innovants c'est pas vrai
que pour les médicaments anciens donc
c'est pour ça que là
l'Europe entière serait probablement
plus forte pour lutter
pour imposer un certain nombre de
contraintes que la France toute seule
je sais pas si j'ai totalement répondu à
votre question mais voilà
alors les bonnes pratiques
alors ça c'est un sujet qui existe même
en dehors des pénuries sur lequel nous
c'est un petit peu nous travaillons
beaucoup les bonnes pratiques et la
pertinence d'utilisation des médicaments
mais je dirais qu'elle se évidemment
elle prend une acuité encore plus
particulière quand tu es une tension sur
un produit donc évidemment voilà là en
effet nous sommes amenés à travailler
avec les professionnels pour trouver des
alternatives et pour
de façon plus générale sur la pertinence
des prescriptions en France on a de très
gros progrès à faire et je parle pas des
médicaments en tension là je parle
globalement on a de très gros progrès à
faire
certains pays qu'on nous cite souvent en
exemple comme l'Allemagne
certes payent peut-être mieux ces
professionnels de santé mais ils en ont
des contraintes de prescription qui sont
beaucoup plus fortes c'est à dire que il
y a des recommandations ils sont censés
bien sûr la médecine et absolument pas
une science exacte c'est-à-dire que
c'est pour ça que ce sont jamais des
recommandations c'est du droit mou c'est
pas des droitures c'est parce que les
situations cliniques en médecine sont
tellement variées qu'il faut vraiment
laisser la latitude aux professionnels
d'apprécier
la situation clinique mais néanmoins
je sais mes collègues allemands quand
ils sont hors des clous que pour une
prescription
s'ils ne le justifie pas et bien le
patient n'est pas remboursé donc je peux
vous dire que ils sont beaucoup moins
souvent des clous et qu'il le justifie
donc voilà alors ça c'est une réflexion
générale mais évidemment c'est d'autant
plus important sur des médicaments
les antibiotiques vous savez que ça a
d'autres répercussions sur
environnementales qui sont extrêmement
importantes
parce que je vois que en terme
d'horaires on
a peur
je suis je vous remercie beaucoup je
vous remercie beaucoup non non donc
merci beaucoup de vos réponses donc on
va je propose qu'on passe la parole au
membre de la commission qui souhaite
vous interroger donc j'ai reçu dans
l'ordre les demandes de questions de
Madame Borge chaud Fontain madame
Humbert monsieur Milon et Madame arrivée
si vous en êtes d'accord vous posez les
questions les uns après les autres en
faisant court contenu de vos délais
voilà de façon à ce que les premières
réponses puissent se faire voilà merci
madame la présidente madame la
présidente Madame la Directrice Générale
mes chers collègues merci d'avoir pour
vos propos liminaires vous l'avez
compris vous ouvrez les travaux de notre
commission d'enquête
je vais vous poser directement la
question pour gagner du temps alors
comme vous le savez bien sûr le cancer
demeure la cause la principale cause la
première cause d'ailleurs en France de
décès chez l'homme et la deuxième chez
femme quant aux enfants ils sont près de
500 à ne pas remporter le combat contre
la maladie chaque année face à une
population vieillissante l'augmentation
des cancers est quasiment mathématique
et pourtant les chiffres parlent
d'eux-mêmes puisque de 10 à 15% des
médicaments en pénurie sont utilisés
dans le cadre de traitement contre le
cancer alors pour pallier à ce manque
l'Agence nationale de la sécurité du
médicament et des produits de santé bien
d'autoriser donc les pharmacies on en a
parlé à produire elle-même de la
motiline mais à titre exceptionnel et
temporaire c'était l'objet de la visite
de ce jour la Ligue de contre le cancer
réclame la création d'un établissement
public du médicament qui travaillerait
de manière coordonnée dans le cadre
d'une participation publique privée je
rappelle que trois cancérologues sur 4
ont déjà été confrontés à une pénurie de
médicaments pour leur patient donc ma
question est la suivante pensez-vous que
la création d'un tel établissement
permettrait une meilleure gestion des
stocks et ainsi qu'une meilleure
anticipation je vous remercie
une petite remarque et puis deux
questions très courtes la petite
remarque c'est aussi beaucoup de temps
gaspillés pour dans le milieu
pharmaceutique
voilà beaucoup de temps médical
gaspiller mais beaucoup de temps en
pharmacie
idem deux questions au regard de ce que
vous avez dit en introduction vous avez
évoqué les logiciels d'aide à la
prescription dans quel délai moyen
sont-ils interrogiciels des
professionnels de santé est-ce que vous
le savez parce que ça doit vous demander
du temps de l'énergie vous allez
produire quelque chose de qualité mais
si ça arrive dans les logiciels trois
mois après ben c'est un peu dommage et
deuxième question vous avez dit
ce pomme méchant non plus comme question
c'est pas c'est pour vous épargner du
temps
excusez-nous deuxième question vous avez
évoqué le M1 donc l'Agence européenne du
médicament et vous avez dit que elle
s'était vu donner de nouvelles missions
est-ce que de façon très courte nous
dire quelles étaient ses nouvelles
missions je vous remercie
si c'est pas court vous ne répondrez par
écrit alors Monsieur Milou oui
merci
je vais j'ai pas de question
j'ai deux observations à faire d'abord
madame la Présidente
la première c'est que j'ai reçu
l'invitation pour cette réunion
d'aujourd'hui hier c'est un peu court je
suppose que c'est peut-être parce
qu'elle n'est pas présent la première
réunion j'aimerais les recevoir à
l'avance parce que la Commission
m'intéresse beaucoup et première chose
la deuxième chose et on est très heureux
de vous compter parmi nous j'imagine oui
je suis pas sûr ça durera mais on verra
ça par la suite
vous avez dit
Laurence a dit que
vos invités recevaient les questions
je faisais en sorte quand je prisais les
commissions que les commissaires
reçoivent les questions en même temps
que les rapporteurs et donc il est
jean-contestent ça pourrait être très
intéressant que nous puissions recevoir
les questions en même temps de manière à
pouvoir les étudier et à pouvoir un peu
plus titiller nos invités
je prends bonne note de vos remarques
chers collègues et que je prends avec
beaucoup de comment dire d'humilité et
auquel je souscris pleinement et
entièrement soyez-en assurés je n'en
doute pas sur l'instant et j'ai une
proposition à faire bon
j'ai bien écouté ce qui a dit Madame la
prison de la Haute Autorité santé je
m'étais d'ailleurs posé la question de
savoir pourquoi c'était la Haute
Autorité santé qui était convoquée dans
une première réunion dans la mesure où
la pénurie de médicaments n'est pas
directement dans ses compétences et
j'aurais aimé j'aimerais
[Musique]
tour de table de questions auprès de la
présidente et de la rapidité
mais je veux dire j'aimerais j'aimerais
revoir madame la Présidente
dans quelques temps quand on aura déjà
eu plus d'éléments sur la pénurie et sur
le sur la façon dont
les observations qui ont été faites par
elles sont intéressantes en particulier
celle que vous avez faites madame la
prison sur l'impact de la France par
rapport à la stratégie mondiale des
laboratoires pharmaceutiques je crois
que c'est important et je suis d'accord
avec vous sur la fête qu'il faut donner
plus de pouvoir aller ma en particulier
mais
je pense
et je vous fais une proposition madame
la rapporteur madame la Présidente que
il faudra ne plus convoquer des agences
un par un parce qu'il nous disent des
choses qu'on est bien obligé de gober
puisqu'on a pas en face ce qu'ils
doivent dire le contraire et par exemple
j'aimerais que si on provoque le CEPS on
covoit qu'en face de laboratoires
pharmaceutiques pour qu'ils puissent
discuter et que nous on puisse retirer
la substantifique well donc j'ai pas de
question directe je vous remercie madame
présidente Madame et fils d'avoir fait
l'effort de venir à cette commission et
j'espère vous revoir après que nous
serons plus instruits
donc madame la présidente madame
directrice évidemment ne sont pas
parjures et bien évidemment
nous ne faisons pas preuve d'une naïveté
excessive et elle n'utilise pas
évidemment des paroles qui sont
inappropriées ou inexactes
merci madame la Présidente
auparavant je tiens m'excuser je dois
partir à 30 donc j'espère que la réponse
parcourtoisie aussi à votre égard je
vous prie de m'excuser vous avez bien
dit que en fait vous réalisiez des
évaluations
médico-économiques qui servent de base à
la fixation
des prix enfin dans le cadre du CEPS qui
négocie mais quand on parle de
d'évaluation médico-économique on est
bien obligé à un moment donné
d'introduire des éléments économiques or
la rentabilité
de du médicament fait partie de ces de
ces critères là et je vous avais dit à
juste titre que l'industrie
pharmaceutique était une industrie
mondialisée mais on a une kérielle de
PME qui travaille souvent sur la
production de médicaments génériques et
qui eux aujourd'hui qui elle aujourd'hui
sont en grande difficulté par rapport à
ce prix de médicament trop bas
est-ce qu'il faut pas complètement
revoir enfin ça c'est votre expérience
indépendamment de la compétence de
l'autorité est-ce qu'il faudrait pas
revoir complètement cette politique de
fixation des prix en fonction de la
nature des médicaments de Magic
médicament d'imatures d'intérêt
thérapeutique majeur et puis des
médicaments innovants parce que je pense
que très on ne peut pas raisonner de la
même manière à la fois sur le plan
scientifique et sur le plan
économique
avec ces deux types de médicaments et la
deuxième question qui avait envie de
vous poser c'est que si on poursuit le
raisonnement
à un moment donné on va se poser la
question du prix et si on se pose la
question du prix du médicament c'est
aussi par rapport à la santé publique
un enjeu de santé publique est-ce que on
pourrait pas imaginer
une production un accord partenariat
public privé un peu comme les américains
l'ont fait avec avec le projet Civica
qui associe près de 900 hôpitaux publics
à la fabrication de médicaments et qui
donc
finalement distingue ce qui est du
domaine de la recherche et de
l'innovation et ce qui est du domaine du
médicament pas basique c'est pas le
terme exact mais en tout cas voilà je
pense qu'on est arrivé à un moment où la
politique de santé doit être
complètement revue et réfléchi
y compris en intégrant la question
européenne dans cette dans cette
organisation là je vous remercie
vous partez alors je dirais que je me
suis mal fait comprendre parce que ce
que dont j'ai parlé il existe une
évaluation spécifique pour l'évaluation
médico-économique des produits qui sait
receps pour la fixation du prix mais qui
ne se fait que pour les médicaments
qu'on des impacts budgétaires très
importants dont j'ai parlé avant c'est
une évaluation médicale scientifique
pure
qu'est-ce qu'apporte le médicament pour
la santé du patient et qu'est-ce qu'il
apporte en plus par rapport au reste et
la France par rapport à d'autres pays a
voulu totalement dissocier cette étude
scientifique médicale et c'est pour ça
que la chaise c'est une notoriété
publique indépendante aussi de
l'évaluation médico-économique et de la
du coup pour pour le régulateur je
dirais ce qui c'est pas que c'est pas
important mais voilà il y a des pays
comme l'Angleterre qui associent les
deux et qui n'évaluent un produit que
sur du médico-économique ce n'est pas le
cas en France et a priori dans le
nouveau règlement européen d'évaluation
des produits de santé ce n'est pas le
cas non plus c'est à dire que là c'est
vraiment une évaluation médicale donc ça
je tenais les ensuite
faut-il changer la politique de fixation
des prix alors vraiment ça dépasse mes
compétences je pense que c'est c'est
vraiment un problème très complexe et
qui vraiment avec beaucoup de d'aspects
qui ne sont vraiment très peu médicales
je le crains vous dites que les
médicaments innovants sont très
différents des anciens médicaments c'est
vrai c'est vrai puis c'est surtout que
on a vu exploser le prix des nouveaux
médicaments je veux dire quand les
médicaments de l'hépatite sont arrivés
souvenez-vous vu que il y avait des
populaires une population très
importante à traiter les prix de 200.000
euros paraissaient astronomique moi
quand je suis arrivé à la chasse
l'innovation la plus chère quand je l'ai
vu arriver elle coûtait un million
d'euros le traitement c'était voilà là
maintenant on voit des produits à un
million d'eau donc je veux dire on voit
bien que les coûts les prix des
innovations
n'ont rien à voir avec les coûts de
développement ou de recherche et sont
basés sur autre chose qui est la vérité
à payer des plus riches de ce monde et
ensuite la France enfin je dirais qu'on
est bien obligé c'est cranter comme ça
et on est bien obligé de suivre sinon
les laboratoires ne nous livreront pas
les médicaments donc bon ça c'est des
considérations donc après faut-il pour
certains produits produire en France
est-ce que les expériences qu'on a fait
dans d'autres domaines ont été
concluants ou pas ça mérite d'être
évalué
on a des des pharmacies centrales on en
a trois en france pharmacie des hôpitaux
de l'Assistance publique on a on a trois
trois
il y en a trois
voilà exactement est-ce qu'il faut leur
donner un autre rôle pour certains
produits là encore il y a énormément de
facteurs qui rentrent en cause
enfin en question et je n'aurais pas eu
de réponse univoque
toujours est-il que c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui on paye très très cher les
nouveaux médicaments qui arrivent
faut-il payer très cher aussi des
anciens et qu'est-ce qui reste de
l'ondamment pour le reste
ça finit par devenir une question
globale c'est-à-dire on voit bien que
nos hôpitaux aient actuellement non plus
suffisamment de ressources donc
quelle est la velléité à payer et à quel
prix mais en sachant que quand même il
faut le savoir les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques si le prix ne leur
convient pas ils vont ailleurs je veux
dire on est plus c'est plus des marchés
captifs
donc c'est un risque aussi qu'on veut
pas faire courir à nos patients de ne
pas avoir accès à une innovation à un
médicament et c'est pour ça qu'on les
paye si cher
voilà alors pour ce qui est du temps des
pharmaciens
je partage totalement c'est à dire que
tout ça demande beaucoup de temps aux
professionnels de santé en général voilà
je n'ai pas d'idées précis sur le temps
moyen d'implantation par les éditeurs je
sais que c'est une implante pas dans des
délais raisonnables ils ont des
pénalités mais quand même temps
on n'a pas sur les logiciels sur la
caisse voilà sur les logiciels
nous n'avons pas de retour je crois
personne ne ressens c'est exactement
est-ce que quelqu'un est chargé d'un
recensement
et d'un contrôle de ses délais je ne
suis pas sûr
l'image en avait déjà parlé je crois
qu'en effet les masses et vu confier des
missions des missions dans le cadre
justement comme la NSM la gestion de des
produits en tension mais au niveau
européen et que les travaux n'ont pas
démarré encore mais je pense que c'est
en effet à l'échelon européen qu'on peut
avoir un petit poids sur les industriels
et très peu à l'échelon national et puis
puis un établissement public du
médicament j'ai répondu c'est vraiment
une problématique complexe mais sur
cette point là je suis sûr que Fabienne
dans ses anciennes fonctions puisqu'elle
a dirigé la NSM par le passé a peut-être
d'autres éléments donc
c'est vrai que c'est important de enfin
à vrai dire bon c'est dommage parce que
la sénatrice qui a posé la question et
est partie
voilà c'est ça mais mais non mais pour
que je lui pose la question d'exactement
ce qu'elle entendait par un
établissement public privé du médicament
enfin ça me paraissait vraiment très
large donc je ne sais pas vraiment
répondre à cette question tout ce que je
peux vous dire c'est puisque j'étais
dans d'autres fonctions mais en tout cas
j'étais dans des fonctions
ministérielles quand la HS a été créé et
donc la Commission de la transparence et
l'acnédims qui est la commission pour
les dispositifs médicaux ont quitté
l'ancienne hassaps pour créer la HS avec
en s'agglomérant à la NES
ce qui est ce que ce que le législateur
à l'époque avait en tête c'est vraiment
de d'assurer l'indépendance de
l'expertise scientifique du
remboursement et donc d'avoir vraiment
une expertise scientifique qui soit
transparente
rigoureuse faites sur des bases claires
accessibles à tous et qui permettrait à
toutes les professionnels toutes les
parties prenantes les citoyens les
professionnels de santé d'avoir une
visibilité sur les critères qui
permettaient au nom d'admettre un
produit au remboursement et voir de le
désinscrire également de le radis et du
remboursement comme ça a été fait assez
récemment sur l'homéopathie notamment où
le rôle est l'indépendance de l'achat
sont été primordiaux pour garantir si
vous voulez que les critères selon
lesquels la Haute Autorité de Santé
avait évalué ces produits et avait rendu
son avis en donnant un service médical
rendu insuffisant pour absence de
preuves d'efficacité justement était
accessible à tous et que en tout cas que
ce n'était pas une décision politique
mais que c'était bien une décision
scientifique et je pense que de ce point
de vue là il est important de préserver
surtout après la période qu'on vient de
passer avec le covid et
qui vont sans doute per sur un certain
nombre de sujets sensibles on le voit
encore aujourd'hui je pense que c'est
important de préserver certains
indépendance scientifiques et de la
détacher justement de tout influence je
dirais globale puisque
l'admission au remboursement enfin
l'admission la mise sur le marché et les
autorisations sur le marché ne vous
européens se font au regard des textes
européens donc qui agglomèrent quand
même ce que veulent 27 États membres
jadis 28 d'ailleurs pour les textes en
vigueur aujourd'hui et donc je pense que
c'est important si vous voulez de
distinguer ces deux sujets puisque
effectivement la liberté de circulation
des biens et des services c'est dans les
traités européens donc c'est important
que en termes d'accès au marché cette
autorisation soit européenne en revanche
les systèmes de remboursement comme vous
le savez sont très très différents ne
répondent pas au même critères n'ont pas
les mêmes logiques ni même histoires et
ont beaucoup de complexité je pense que
c'est important d'avoir un
une institution comme la Haute autorité
qui permet de donner une évaluation
indépendante scientifique de qu'est-ce
qu'on retient pour l'admission de
remboursement donc voilà pour répondre à
cette question
juste une précision par rapport à aux
infos enfin aux éléments que vous avez
donné moi effectivement je trouve que
c'est extrêmement important qui est pas
d'évaluation médico-économique il y en a
une mais indépendance
de la Haute Autorité de santé ça me
paraît très important et en même temps
vous nous avez dit cette évaluation de
la de la Haute Autorité donc qui se base
sur je vais le dire le service de santé
rendu voilà
vous dites comme ça il permet de la
transparer mais ce cet évaluation de la
Haute Autorité de santé elle est
directement communiquée
pour l'évaluation des prix ou elle est
parce que je n'ai pas vérifié cet
élément là ou bien elle se trouve en
toute transparence comme on peut voir
dans les comptes rendus de l'Agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament
est-ce que vous est-ce que votre
évaluation
transparente d'un point de vue j'allais
dire tout venant c'est cette question là
que je n'ai pas avant que vous répondiez
on va prendre la dernière question de
Madame Muller Braun et les autres fois
on demandera vraiment à tout le monde de
ce signaler dès le départ ça sera plus
simple pour nos interlocuteurs merci
madame la Présidente c'est une question
qui m'est venue en vous écoutant en fait
concernant par exemple
l'homéopathie vous disiez que c'était
bien un regard scientifique et non pas
un regard politique alors la question
que je me posais c'est est-ce que ce
regard scientifique il est le même pour
toute l'Europe puisque si on parle vous
avez évoqué l'homéopathie il y a des
pays européens qui qui ont un autre
regard et si c'est un regard
scientifique on peut imaginer que il y a
pas de frontière et la science étant
voilà c'est ma question est vous l'avez
comprise oui oui tout à fait alors moi
j'ai deux réponses alors d'abord
l'analyse médico-économique elle est
aussi à la chas mais elle est totalement
séparée une commission indépendante la
Commission de la transparence c'est une
commission elle qui fait le médical
enfin la scientifique je dirais médico
voilà service médical rendu et ensuite
et c'est bien aussi qu'il y a une
évaluation médico-économique puisqu'on a
des produits qui arrivent avec des tel
prix faut savoir si c'est ce qu'on
appelle le coût par quoi lise
c'est-à-dire c'est quel est le combien
paye-t-on l'amélioration parce que des
fois on paye très cher une petite
amélioration et des fois voilà il faut
relativiser aussi le coût par rapport à
l'amélioration
pour ce qui est de la transparence chez
nous et la Haute Autorité de santé qui a
été créée par nos assemblées elle a une
totale transparence une obligation
totale transparence à la fois dans ces
travaux dans ces méthodes dans toutes
les débats c'était à la Commission de la
transparence tous les débats sont
enregistrés donc accessibles d'ailleurs
j'ai eu des professionnels hier qui sont
venus hurler parce qu'ils avaient trouvé
une appréciation trop sévère et on peut
en reparler parfois qui pose problème
et donc ils ont écouté tous les débats
de la commission etc donc c'est
accessible sur notre site à qui le veut
tout totalement transparent et je crois
que ça c'est extrêmement important parce
que voilà on peut ne pas être d'accord
avec une
appréciation mais elle est collégiale et
complètement transparente avec des
phases contradictoires c'est à dire
qu'il y a des experts évidemment les
commissions peuvent pas avoir toutes les
expertises toutes les spécialités
médicales sont pas représentées donc on
auditionne aussi des experts extérieurs
et puis si l'industriel n'est pas
contente on appréciation il revient en
face contradictoire il amène aussi des
experts et donc voilà l'ensemble du
processus est totalement transparent je
crois que ça c'est vraiment très
important le regard scientifique c'est
un regard scientifique et j'ajouterai
qu'il y a des patients dans toutes nos
commissions et qu'ils ont un regard
extrêmement pertinent sur l'appréciation
des des médicaments et des innovations
et qu'ils ont vraiment tout pas trop la
jouer extrêmement important d'abord
parce que sur leur vision des
traitements ou des améliorations sur la
qualité de vie qui sont parfois moins
pris en compte par les patients les
médecins qui voient surtout
l'allongement de la durée de vie ou la
guérison je dirais ou la partielle ou
totale mais en tout cas le regard des
patients sur les traitements sur le
comment il les supporte sur les effets
secondaires sur leur Cali la meilleure
ration de leurs qualités de vie sont
extrêmement importantes donc je dirais
que cette transparence
cette participation des patients est
très très importante alors ce regard
scientifique alors je dirais sur le
homéopathie on est les seuls le seul
pays à avoir évalué scientifiquement le
PO homéopathie sur la demande d'Agnès
Buzin à l'époque qui pour je dirais
mettre fin à des controverses voulaient
qu'ils évaluation et voilà nous ce que
nous avons dit humblement aux personnes
qui parce que nous avions fait une
consultation publique dans nos méthodes
en particulier pour les vaccins mais
aussi certains médicaments très
sensibles socialement sociétalement nous
faisons des consultations publiques et
nous avons dit nous disons pas que c'est
inefficace pour certains patients nous
disons qu'il n'y a pas de preuves
d'efficacité dans ce que nous avons pu
réunir à la fois dans la littérature
extensive vraiment et à la fois dans
dans ce que ce que nous ont dit les
professionnels de santé
mais ce regard alors sinon en dehors
d'un sujet particulier comme ça notre
analyse elle est basée sur des dossiers
déposés par les laboratoires des
dossiers d'études de différentes phases
il y a des phases 1 2 3 etc et ces
dossiers là ce sont les mêmes en général
pour tous les pays de l'Europe
c'est-à-dire que et les critères d'après
alors les méthodes d'évaluation sont pas
les mêmes c'est tout le travail qui est
en train d'être fait en ce moment par
mes équipes c'est travailler avec toutes
les autres pays européens pour avoir une
démarche commune une évaluation qui
convienne à l'ensemble des pays
européens c'est pas si simple mais en
tout cas ce regard sur le plan du regard
scientifique de l'appréciation
scientifique
il peut être il peut être mis en commun
après il restera à chaque pays ce qu'on
appelle le jugement de valeur
c'est-à-dire et ce qu'il veut rembourser
ou pas et le prix qu'il est prêt à payer
ça c'est national mais l'analyse
scientifique des dossiers peut être
partagée
merci beaucoup de ces réponses
assez complète vraiment madame la
Présidente et Emmanuel
est-ce que vous souhaitez porter
d'autres éléments à la connaissance de
la Commission dans
ce que nous avons pas forcément abordé
toutes les questions et à titre
personnel je je
j'ai juste une questionnement c'est sur
la question de la saisine sur le service
médical rendu et l'amélioration du
service médical rendu est-ce que c'est
une auto-césine est-ce ce qui vous
arrive de vous auto saisir un peu comme
ça parce que vous sentez qu'un sujet
pourrait émerger ou est-ce qu'il faut
qu'il y ait une saisine un peu
officiel sur les sujets et est-ce qu'il
y a des saisies ne systématiques à
l'arrivée d'un d'un nouveau médicament
puisque
en réalité votre votre avis est
essentiel on l'a vécu pendant la période
de la covid la grosse phase épidémique
euh et les vaccinations mais on voit
bien que ce que vous apportez est un
regard différent et justement parce que
c'est pas exactement la même chose que
le regard économique et la question du
remboursement
vous participez pleinement politique de
santé publique et notamment de du soin
tout alors je dirais qu'il y a deux
types d'entrée dans dans nos travaux
tout ce qui est évaluation des produits
ou des actes médicaux en vue d'un
remboursement alors pour les produits de
santé ce sont des industriels qui
déposent un dossier chez nous et nous
évaluons un produit nous ne pouvons
l'évaluer d'ailleurs que quand un
industriel nous dépose un produit et
nous demande de l'évaluer voilà donc ça
c'est une entrée par contre pour tout ce
qui est recommandations de votre
pratique pertinence etc nous travaillons
sur ces îles du ministère des
associations des conseils nationaux
professionnels et pour certains sujets
en auto saisie pour les médicaments il y
a quand même des travaux qui sont en
auto saisine c'est quand nous voulons
réévaluer toute une classe de
médicaments il par exemple des arrivées
successives de des améliorations des
nouveaux médicaments en masse et nous
voulons avoir à nouveau une vue globale
sur le traitement des différentes phases
d'un traitement diabète etc quand les
choses ont suffisamment changé et quand
nous y arrivons parce que ça demande
beaucoup de ressources et que vu le
nombre de dossiers qui arrivent on a
beaucoup de mal et pour le vaccin je ne
vous cacherai pas qu'on a beaucoup de
mal à assurer quand nous y arriverions
nous prenons le temps de revoir
complètement une classe thérapeutique et
ça la stratégie d'utilisation de chacun
et de chaque médicament et ça ça demande
du temps c'est très utile aux patients
et aux prescripteurs en particulier
je dirais juste pour terminer que il y a
deux pour moi il y a deux aspects
différents il y a la prévention des
pénuries avec des aspects industriels
qui qui sont complexes et qui me
dépassent beaucoup enfin on peut essayer
de gérer et d'essayer de prévenir mais
il faut vraiment se mettre tous autour
de la table et travailler pour voir
comment on peut limiter je dirais et
puis après il y a la gestion de la
pénurie après et où là on est fait plus
on anticipe les choses et mieux on se
porte parce que comme moi on est des
processus de travail coordonnés de façon
à apporter une réponse rapide aux
professionnels et aux patients et donc
pour la gestion de la pénurie elle-même
pas pour l'anticipation mais pour le bon
pour l'anticipation aussi la pour la
prévention l'anticipation est importante
aussi mais je dirais que
l'anticipation de la gestion de la
pénurie de l'information des
professionnels
de des outils pour arriver à à leur
faciliter le travail dans ces
conditions-là et extrêmement importante
que là on a des progrès tout à fait
juste pardon
de la prévention des pénurie je vous
rejoins complètement mais
quand on demande au ministre de faire de
la prévention de la pénurie ils ont tous
le syndrome Bachelot quand même si vous
achat N1 on avait beaucoup acheté de
vaccins beaucoup acheter de tamiflux
beaucoup acheter etc qui n'ont
finalement pas servi à qui on a reproché
ensuite à une bise d'avoir trop acheté
donc il y a une limite à tout c'est pour
ça que je dis que c'est très complexe
c'est que je me garde bien de donner une
solution univoque parce que je pense que
c'est en effet très complexe
il faut pas mettre de l'argent non plus
dans ce qui va passer servir voilà et
puis les process de industriels sont ce
qu'ils sont
je ne sais pas si c'est un établissement
public qui est le plus
âme donc c'est la mission je demande
vraiment c'est très compliqué
disons-le il y a quand même les
anticipations classiques les crises
épidémiques hivernales et notamment
concernant les nourrissons ça fait
partie des et les besoins en corticoïdes
en gouttes par exemple pour ne citer que
cette question là c'est quelque chose
qu'on peut anticiper donc il y a le
conjoncturel et il y a le structure
[Musique]